Hi, it's almost time to say goodbye,
but we have a little time left
for some of your questions.
First up is a Twitter question
from Camille, she asked,
what has your experience
on the #DrewBarrymoreShow
taught you so far?
Wow, you would think, you know,
only having been on the air a week.
I wouldn't know much,
but we've actually been
in this for many months
over a year, trying to
get this show launched,
so I have learned a lot.
And the truth is (claps)
I think that this show is inspiring me
to really be the best version of myself
that I have ever been.
It's what my kids do for me.
But this show, just like
my friends and loved ones
they all just want to make me--
they make me want to be a better person.
That's the truth answer.
All right, let's get a question
from our virtual friends,
Crystal, what do you got for me?
(gaps)
- Hi Drew, how are you?
- Oh, I am loving your look.
- Thank you.
Well, just like you,
I'm a mom of three
and my young adults are
spread out in the Midwest.
I wanna know how you balance
this fantastic career
plus your most important role
being a mom to Frankie and Olive.
- You know, that's the most
important question, honestly.
And the truth is, is that
I always sort of have an internal clock
where I know
that it's just--
it's been too much work
and I gotta get back to the kids.
And we all feel like
when we're with our kids,
that we're dropping balls at work.
This is a natural seesaw
of parenthood and professional life.
But my kids come first
and it's how I live my life,
and I'm very disciplined about
it, but I'll tell you this.
It never feels like
I'm pulling it all off.
So anyone else who beats
themselves up there,
let's try to change that.
Cause I am fault--
I am at fault of that too.
Thank you Crystal, for your question.
We wanna thank you.
(audience claps)
And if you wanna be one
of our virtual friends
come see us and get (claps)
your tickets right now
at the Drewbarrymoreshow.com.
(upbeat music)